you
okay we're going to shift now to the
presentation for our first speaker
dr. Tracy Lasky received her PhD in
entomology from the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst she has been
employed as a research entomologist for
usda-ars at the Appalachian fruit
research station in kearneysville West
Virginia since 2010 her research focuses
on behavioral and chemical ecology of
economically important tree fruit pests
and specifically on developing
behaviorally based monitoring tools and
management strategies for the brown
marmorated stink bug plum curculio apple
maggot fly and dogwood boar Tracy yes
can you hear me Kathy yes okay okay I'll
go ahead then yes so today I am going to
talk about brown marmorated stink bug
and its emergence as a serious pest of
Agriculture here in the mid-atlantic to
begin with brown marmorated stink bug is
considered an invasive species and it is
native to China Japan Korea and Taiwan
it's defined as an invasive species
because it has been introduced into an
area for which it naturally does not
occur in this case north america and
also because it threatens both
environmental and economic resources due
to the damage it causes in this case to
agricultural crops now a little bit
about the identification of brown
marmorated stink bug if you haven't seen
these insects yet the adults you'll see
on the right hand side of the screen the
lower right with the male and the female
they have very prominent white stripes
on their antennae you can see the small
arrow that's pointing at the left
antennae of the male / male a stink bug
on the outer edges of the abdomen there
are alternating patterns of white and
dark markings and this is actually why
it is referred to as the marmorated
stink bug it's another term anat for
describing that appearance the underside
is generally pale with some gray or
black markings and of course they emit a
very pungent odor when disturbed hence
they're called stink bugs and I can tell
you if you
haven't smelled it previously it smells
very different than our native species
and some people often detect an odor of
cilantro when that when they handle this
bug although it is much more pungent
than just the odor of cilantro now the
eggs in the upper right hand corner our
barrel straight and when they're first
laid their kind of bright green but they
turn white in general they're laid on
the undersides of leaves in masses and
there are typically 28 eggs per mass the
female lays eggs in intervals of 7
typically the nymphs you see the first
instar nymphs they're just below the
eggs the nymphs typically the first
instars will be near the hatched eggs
and they will remain there the seconds
through the fifths are very mobile and
in fact they've been described as sort
of tick like when they're climbing
around on foliage but you can see that
they typically also have that those
white stripes on the antenna and again
that's a good way to define if these are
brown marmorated stink bug nims now a
little bit about the history of brown
marmorated stink bug and these comments
are related principally to tree fruit
because this is where we've seen the
most injury at least that were most
familiar with this insect has thought to
have been introduced into the united
states somewhere between the mid to late
1990s it showed up in Allentown
Pennsylvania in nineteen ninety nine
eight but the first properly identified
specimen didn't occur until 2001 when
specimens were sent by Karen Bernhardt
who was is who is with Penn State
Cooperative Extension she sent those to
Cornell to Rick hobak who confirmed they
were indeed brown marmorated the
following year in 2002 they were
confirmed in New Jersey and then we
confirmed their presence in Maryland in
Hagerstown in 2003 we found them in West
Virginia in 2004 and they continue to
spread now there was a bit of a lag
period between those introductions and
detections and serious injury and in the
eastern panhandle of west virginia we
actually did not see injury until two
thousand eight when the first reports of
late season injury appeared then in 2009
we began to see both nymphs and adults
in order
words throughout the middle of the
season and there was very serious injury
in 2009 and then of course in 2010 this
was really a watershed year where we saw
injury and tree fruit small fruit
vegetables row crops and in vineyards
and throughout the mid-atlantic states
including West Virginia Maryland New
Jersey Delaware Virginia and
Pennsylvania now this is a distribution
map of brown marmorated stink bug
throughout the 48 continental United
States so the red indicates states where
we have seen both severe agricultural
problems as well as nuisance problems
from the fall immigration of bugs from
host plants to potential overwintering
sites the yellow states are highlighted
in that they have had reports of
nuisance problems in the fall with
homeowners but no agricultural injury
reported yet however when you see these
yellow states with that is indicative
indicative of is establishing
populations where the populations are
beginning to increase and then of course
the green states mean that we've had
specimens detected but no injury
reported and no nuisance problems
reported and so at this point brown
marmorated stink bug has been detected
officially in 33 states and the District
of Columbia now the reason we were very
interested in brown marmorated and when
I found the first specimen back in 2003
we began tracking it was because we were
seeing increasing injury from our native
species and in the mid-atlantic we have
three the brown and dusky stink bug you
justice service and try stigmas and the
great green stink bug accra sternum
hilari and entry fruit this is the
typical injury that we find from native
stink bugs where on peaches we see the
cat facing in gum OSIS early in the
season and then on apple which was
typically late season injury we see
these Corky indented depressions again
this is with our native species and
really the reason for that injury has to
do with the changes in our management
programs over the years after the advent
of fq PA where we began to shift from
our broader spectrum materials to more
specific chemistry's that were softer on
beneficials and that sort of thing so we
were
really removing those broad-spectrum
materials from the system and what this
did was really allowed increased injury
from secondary pests like native stink
bugs so during that time we were
developing monitoring tools for native
stink bugs to determine the need for and
timing of insecticide applications and
here you can see the yellow ground
deploy pyramid trap that we had
developed over a number of years we also
were working on attracting kill
strategies for native stink bugs as well
and so for a number of years we weren't
seeing any injury as i mentioned from
brown marmorated however in late two
thousand eight and 2009 this is what we
began to observe in commercial orchards
you see on the upper part of the slide
mature peach with adult brown marmorated
stink bugs feeding and if you peel that
skin away this is the typical injury we
would see this Corky dried tissue
beneath and blow as an apple with the
large indented depressions again from
brown marmorated stink bug feeding so in
2009 we were actually having quite a bit
of economic injury here in the Eastern
Panhandle this is just one example of a
commercial apple orchard a family-run
operation they have about 1,100 acres
they produce about a half million
bushels annually and by 2009 brown
marmorated stink bug was their
number-one pest and nearly ten percent
of all the fruits they harvested in this
case 45 thousand bushels of apples had
to be redirected from fresh market to
processing due to brown marmorated stink
bug injury and certainly for commercial
growers the loss of valuers somewhere
between 80 and 90 percent so again
already a tremendous past in 2009 the
other thing that we observed was a
tremendously large overwintering
population these photographs were taken
on the our building here at the lab at
the Appalachian fruit Research Station
so you can see the adults aggregating on
the sides of the building on the lower
left you can see the the bumper of
someone's vehicle with brown marmorated
stink bugs and this really highlights
the fact that they are excellent
hitchhikers and can be taken to new
areas just because of this this behavior
we see in the fall where they aggregate
in in tight quarters including
vehicles and then we also had problems
with them actually clogging our air
intake vent which you see in the upper
right so what I'm going to do now is
sort of take you through what we learned
in terms of 2010 and the field season in
terms of the different hosts that were
attacked and the types of injury that we
observed in the winter of 2010 we had a
tremendous snowfall here in the
mid-atlantic something we are not very
familiar with but so there was a lot of
snow cover and the question is did that
snow cover in some way help round
marmorated stink bug overwinter more
effectively in other words we had higher
survivorship the answer is we don't know
at this point but certainly it's a
question we have to address and so what
we learn next was by april 2010 much
earlier than we had ever observed before
we began to spot brown marmorated stink
bugs in some of our experimental
orchards here on the farm but also out
in commercial origins well and so we
began photographing them just to sort of
document that early season activity but
we presume because many orchard cover
sprays are going on at this time this
would protect the fruit from any injury
from brown marmorated so here you can
see it's May 5th in their feeding on
Montmorency cherry here they are on May
tenth feeding on alluring peach it's
about 20 millimeters in diameter granny
smith apple on June tenth and suckle
pair also on June tenth and so you're
starting to get an idea of the number of
different hosts this insect will feed
upon and so again we were hoping the
cover sprays would be controlling this
insect but indeed that was not the case
so by late June we were starting to see
the first evidence of this early season
activity in commercial orchards and in
this case it was very specific to stone
fruit this is a peach that is immature
and what you're seeing on the surface is
a bit of gum OSIS on the left but when
you cut that open this is something
that's very unique to brown marmorated
stink bug we saw these pockets of dead
and sort of gumede right issue
internally in the fruit because of that
early
seasoned feeding and and it appears to
us as the fruit expanded these pockets
also expanded as well we also began to
observe something that was very
different from our native species which
is not only was it adult feeding but
also nympho feeding typically from our
native species we really only worried
about the adults and then the final
major difference was that we were
learning that in fact brown marmorated
stink bug could reproduce in commercial
orchards with our native species they
typically would reproduce on broadleaf
weeds and then move into orchards but
this was not the case with brown
marmorated so here we are on July 21st
and you can see both adults and names
feeding on peaches and mature peaches in
commercial orchards and you can see the
gum OSIS and injury then by the late
July we began to really see the
devastation from this insect these are
some photographs taken from commercial
orchards that had total losses of their
early-season peach varieties in this
case the grower made the decision to
strip those trees and allow the fruit to
rot on the ground because it was
essentially a hundred percent loss and
you can look up through this orchard and
just every fruit that's on the ground
had just extensive brown marmorated
stink bug injury from that early season
feeding then we began to see the other
host that this insect would attack in
this case this is field corn and so you
can see both adults and limbs feeding
through the husk on the kernels and what
happens is the kernels do not develop
properly they also feed on sweet corn
and when they do the kernels turn brown
because of brown marmorated stink bug
feeding on silk they were interwork
implicated in interfering with
pollination and then we had a number of
farmers as they were cutting the corn
for silage the brown marmorated stink
bugs in the fields were so thick at that
time literally they had to turn on their
windshield wipers and so from that then
the question is that silage that was
created would this deter cattle from
feeding on it because of the presence of
the brown marmorated stink bugs and if
it did not could it in fact taint the
milk because of those defensive compound
from the insect so this is an open
question as well now we also saw
extensive injury on raspberries where
they were feeding on the fruit and this
was both again nymphs and adults and
severe feeding leads to the fruit not
coming free of the receptacle and also
we started to see sort of died back at
the tips of the shoots which again we
think may have something to do either
with their salivary enzymes or perhaps
they're introducing something into the
plant that could again be causing this
died back at the tips that we're seeing
they also attack a number of vegetable
crops including tomatoes you can see the
injury on the surface on that ripe
tomato and you can see the numbers they
really do like tomatoes as well as well
as bell peppers we saw a lot of injury
on bell peppers and you can see the
injury the dry Corky tissue beneath the
surface it wasn't limited to vegetables
in this case this is a row crops and so
in the center where you see the part of
the field that is referred to as
unaffected where the the soybean plants
are starting to dry and siness this is
typically what we would see but around
the edges of fields where you see that
green area that is from brown marmorated
stink bug feeding and the plants do not
sucess properly there's sort of a
vegetative response they remain green
and so the pods do not develop properly
the beans do not develop properly and
this was a major issue for soy green
soybean growers here in the mid-atlantic
and so the soybeans could not to be
developed or sorry harvested correctly
and of course there was losses as well
they also at late August we see this
intense late season fury feeding period
be just prior to them entering
overwintering and so on Apple what we
began to see was really serious injury
and so hit this is a pink lady apple
just about six to eight weeks before
harvest you see the fruit is quite deep
in the the injury is quite deep in the
fruits flesh and so obviously this is
unacceptable for fresh market and again
if it's redirected to processing the
loss of value can be up to ninety
percent we have a number of growers that
we're in this position and so now the
question is what are the processor is
going to be doing in 2011 because this
injury is very deep it's very difficult
for them to peel out and so there may be
new requirements also due to the
extensive feeding there may have been
questions of premature drop of the fruit
now we also sell them feeding on
ornamental nursery crops here they are
feeding on Norway maple on the left and
a newly planted peach tree on the right
and we don't really know what impact
that feeding may have but certainly with
the numbers that were out there we were
concerned we also saw them feeding on
grape late in the season this became an
issue for a number of vineyards who had
to get them out of the clusters or the
lugs because of issues potentially with
taint to the wine of course the feeding
themselves causes collapse of the
berries and there were also a presence
of increased rots despite the fact it
was a very dry year so those are those
are the issues in grape we also saw them
in nut crops these are pictures of
hazelnuts with feeding injury as well so
you can see the host range is extremely
broad so that took us to harvest but in
fact the injury did not end there
because in throughout the mid-atlantic
growers who put fruit into storage at
harvest seemingly clean four to five
weeks later we're starting to see injury
emerge from this late season feeding
that occurred during that pre-harvest
interval late in the season just prior
to harvest and so it's not visible when
the injury first occurs but several
weeks later it appears and so in the
mid-atlantic we've had there's been some
surveys done by us APPL with growers
reporting or some of these storage
facilities reporting up to sixty percent
of the fruit coming out of cold storage
having injury so serious serious
problems so what's been going on well at
the national level one of the issues was
just getting the word out and so back in
September we held a meeting at two
commercial orchards in Maryland Catoctin
Mountain and garden hour and this really
brought together both the leadership
from USDA as well as other government
agencies state departments of Ag and the
research and Extension community to look
at this problem and really get people
talking about the issues and so this is
one of the events that really has been
useful
another has been the press and
interestingly the press really started
to pick up on the crop injury at the
same time when the homeowner issues
begin in the fall when the brown
marmorated stink bugs move to homeowner
sites and probably one of the best
issues our best photographs that
appeared was in the New York Times and
so you can see the headline of the
article move over bedbugs stink bugs
have landed and certainly if you're
competing with bedbugs for press you
know it's a serious problem but you can
see these folks this is about a half an
hour from our lab they are literally
sweeping up brown marmorated stink bugs
into a five-gallon bucket so tremendous
numbers of insects out there the other
group that's been very useful is the
brown marmorated stink bug group working
group that's led by myself and George
Hamilton and this group is designed to
bring the research and extension
community together and so what we are
have been able to do is to develop
priorities for research and extension
and regulatory and in looking at this
list you'll probably be able to see that
really are we are at the beginning in
terms of understanding this insect so
this really leads into the research that
we've been conducting and so one of the
things we've been working on is
developing a monitoring tool for growers
that essentially will allow them to
detect the presence abundance and
seasonal activity of brown marmorated
stink bug and then ultimately to design
behaviorally based strategies like
attract and killer mass trapping so let
me quickly take you through some of the
work that we've done toward a monitoring
tool looking for visual cues that can be
incorporated into a track a trap design
olfactory cues the lures we use a
capture mechanism that is compatible
with their movement patterns and then a
deployment strategy where and when do we
deploy these traps and so what we have
done so far is look at visual cues
associated with a pyramid trap one that
we had used for our native stink bugs
and we evaluated these five different
visual stimuli sources with baited and
unveiled traps over a two-year period
and so we were able to capture a lot of
stink bugs obviously and what we found
was that for both nymphs and adults a
darker
that has baited with a known attractant
is by far superior so here you see adult
captures in 2009 abated black pyramid
trap 2010 there was no difference
between our dark green and black but
with the nymphs as well we're seeing a
baited black pyramid trap being superior
so that's the first piece the second is
what we're doing right now is the fact
that brown marmorated stink bug
interestingly respond to wavelengths and
intensities of light and so in this case
what we've been doing is trying to
discern what are those wavelengths and
intensity so we can incorporate it into
a trap design this picture by the way
was taken at a bank in spring Mills West
Virginia and the size of the aggregation
around this light was estimated to be
about a million individuals so we have a
light bioassay right now that's trying
to capture that information and so you
can see where we're releasing insects
into this arena and tracking their
movement and determining those
wavelengths and intensities we also are
trying to identify the true pheromone
these are headspace collection chambers
that allow us to identify the headspace
volatile is being released by in this
case adult male bugs and so we hope in
collaboration with doctor I jinjiang
who's leading this part of the project
will have a better attractant that we
can use with our traps to really lure
these insects in so that's another piece
of this puzzle in terms of capture
mechanisms and deployment strategies
interestingly there are a few
commercially available traps from Asia
that we were able to get our hands on
and compare with our prototype black
pyramid trap which you see on the right
so in this case the pier the traps that
were available from Japan they were
different in that on the left you see
this clear sort of pyramid trap you
deploy in the canopy of trees compared
with the ground the center is this
yellow water trap that considered to be
visually stimulating to the insect and
again deployed in the tree so we were
able to compare these at our farm and
what we saw was in this case that our
black pyramid trap was superior in terms
of capturing both adults and nymphs and
so compared with these commercially
available traps so again this is where
we are right now in terms of being able
to monitor adult popular and then full
population
shins so just to wrap up this portion we
are using this dark visual stimulus as
our part of our trap design it's a
ground deployed pyramid because both
adults and nymphs have a tendency to
walk up surfaces that's their natural
behavior we have a known attractive it
is particularly good for the nymphs
season long but the adults really don't
respond strongly until later in the
season so identification of a pheromone
is really critical and then we hope to
augment these trap designs with light
based on optimal wavelengths and
intensities now the last piece I want to
talk about with you today before I wrap
up is just the challenges we've observed
in managing brown marmorated stink bug
in commercial plantings because one of
the issues is that brown marmorated
stink bug has an incredibly broad host
range they feed on over 300 different
pant plants and what this means is
tremendous season-long pressure from
populations moving from wild hosts into
cultivated crops like our commercial
orchards in terms of managing them we've
seen greatest efficacy when adults have
direct contact with finished wet spray
material however because they're
constantly immigrating into plot only a
small population have contact with that
material and so that's a problem also
they have incredible avoidance behaviors
that allow them to potentially escape
treatments and finally insecticides that
are labeled as excellent against native
species have not shown the same efficacy
against brown marmorated in fact we have
seen knocked down in recovery from a
number of compounds and other compounds
being completely ineffective so let me
show you this knockdown and recovery
phenomenon so what we did was to treat
1-acre plots with tombstone which is a
pyrethroid or by date a carbamate we
recovered these bugs from these plots
and followed their mortality over time
and the reason we did this is because in
grower orchards where you saw them
spraying pyrethroids particularly like
warrior and a sauna literally eighty
percent of the bugs recovered within 24
to 48 hours and we're climbing back up
into the trees as get incredible as that
sounds that's what happened so in this
case from this small bioassay that we
did what you can see is we tracked more
ality over five days and so at the time
of collection all of the bugs were
moribund meeting they were unable to
move but they were still alive their
antennae or leg might be twitching but
they could not climb vertical surfaces
or move on horizontal surfaces so red is
dead and alive means they are capable of
moving once again and so you can see
that with tombstone by by the end of the
the trial about a third of them had
recovered from that exposure and so this
was the issue so what we did was to
think about that in designing an
insecticide evaluation that we conducted
over the winter months where we really
needed to deal with what we consider to
be the primary threat those insects that
come in after the spray residue is dry
so in this case what we believe is
control will depend on residual
effectiveness and likelihood of uptake
so our laboratory bioassay was designed
to be biologically relevant based on
that primary threat and so all of the
compounds that we evaluate evaluated
through this three-part trial required
about 24 person hours so this is the
list of materials we have evaluated we
evaluated both carbamates
organophosphates pyrethroids
neonicotinoids we looked at the
organochlorine material Theoden or end
of soften as well as other classes and
newer chemistry's and the three-part
bioassay included first of all using
etho vision which is a software package
that allows us to track their movements
on insecticide-treated dishes in a
horizontal plane so it tracks horizontal
mobility and we would conduct these
trials over a four and a half hour
period where they were exposed to these
dry residues that had been cured for 18
hours then we would remove them from
these dishes and then look at their
capacity for vertical movement so sort
of mimic what may happen if they were
climbing back up into the trees and then
we were tracked mortality for seven days
so I can't go into all of these results
but what I want to show you is the type
of tracks that emerged from first of all
the horizontal mobility where you can
see on the top with water as a control
the bug
kind of me handed around the dishes
there wasn't really any impact but with
warrior a pyrethroid you can see at zero
hours they appear to be very stimulated
within one hour you can see the track
becomes more irregular they're
succumbing and within two hours you can
see it looks like the bugs just about
dead and that's what we would have
interpreted but in fact because of that
knockdown in recovery the all of those
bugs one hundred percent of those tests
had recovered in fact they could even
reproduce so we tracked bug mortality
for seven days and this provided us with
this lethality index and I know this is
a long list of materials but what I
wanted to point out is that we basically
we ranked each of these materials based
on how quickly they succumb to the
material and also the overall rate of
mortality and so you can see that a lot
of materials are older broad spectrum
materials that were most effective so to
wrap this part up in terms of the
insecticide work broad-spectrum
materials including dimethyl eight
malathion bifenthrin method atheon and a
sailfin and methanol provided the
greatest levels of contact lethality now
certainly within each class the patterns
of lethality are similar but there's a
substantial amount of variation between
active ingredients in terms of the
intensity of effects on mobility and
mortality based on the activity of
registered and unregistered compounds as
such an 18-4 Dino tougher on also known
as safari or venom is being pursued for
tree fruit with Virginia as the lead
state this is a mid-atlantic regional
application and in terms of tree fruit
and other crops recommendations are
being put together based on what we have
in the mid-atlantic which is a
season-long threat now I know in other
areas it will probably still be more of
a late-season threat and in other areas
obviously it isn't well established so
in terms of where we are right now we
have formed a nationwide team of 50
research and extension personnel
throughout the US representing 14
institution is in 10 states we've put in
a very large specialty crop research
initiative proposal entitled biology
ecology and management of brown
marmorated stink bug and orchard crop
small fruit grapes vegetables and
ornamentals
and in terms of my labs work we're going
to continue to work on the monitoring
tools and behaviorally based management
strategies but the bottom line for brown
marmorated is that it's going to require
a sustained cooperative collaborative an
integrated approach for research and
extension on a national scale and I will
tell you that certainly within the
strawberry industry folks are going to
be looking for brown marmorated in 2011
and trying to document any problems so
far none have been reported but with the
broad host range we have to be extremely
cautious and and certainly document the
host that this insect may attack so this
is my lab group that work with me on all
of the projects that we're conducting in
there a great bunch of folks and then
finally my colleagues and growers and
others throughout the mid-atlantic in
the US who have worked with me on this
project so I would be happy to take any
questions Kathy if there are any thanks
a lot Tracy are there any questions
okay we'll give you a chance to think
about that and Tracy will be back with
us after Stephen does his presentation
our next speaker is mr. Steven quickie
Steven joined the Monterey County Office
of the University of California
Cooperative Extension in 1989 as a plant
pathology farm advisor steve is involved
in educational programs and applied
research and vegetable fruit and
ornamental crop diseases his research
emphasizes diseases of vegetables
epidemiology of disease systems
fungicide evaluations identification of
new diseases in the ecology of fungi
exploration of alternative disease
control methods such as alternative
fungicides biological agents organic
agricultural disease management steve is
also involved in Applied Research of
foodborne pathogens primarily e.coli as
they occur in agricultural field
settings educational efforts consist of
informing clientele of research results
Taylor results to commercial operations
and diagnosing problems found in field
and greenhouse Steve operates the
University of California Cooperative
Extension Plant Pathology diagnostic lab
located in Salinas and in 2007 he
published his first book a color
handbook of diseases and vegetables
Steve great Thank You Kathy it I see
there's some questions about the stink
but did you want to take those or should
I just go ahead okay I didn't see those
oh let me see I'd be glad I wait if you
want to do this yeah we could do that
for just a second okay Laura McDermott
would like to know Traci if well my
mother stinkbug is a pest of blueberries
yes so Dean poke at Rutgers did document
them feeding on the late-season variety
elliott in 2010 other than that there
hasn't been I mean they're going to be
doing season-long monitoring this year
so that's what I can tell you at this
point okay Pam Fisher would like to know
how it moves to new areas generally we
think that first of all they are spread
in some cases by their their fall
overwintering behaviors and that they
end up in people's belongings and they
move them to a new location but
certainly we've also seen as they
established here in the mid-atlantic
that they move them
selves you know that leading edge of the
population has continued to move through
our region and head south so both of
those are sort of providing the spread i
would say Deb morrow would like to know
if your pyramid traps or patterns
thereof are available for other
collaborators they are we have a
blueprint that's available and also
there is a commercial provider that is
making them this year bio which I can
provide that to you Kathy if you want to
pass both the blueprint and that
information on yes that would be great
bob martin is wondering where they
overwinter and can they be targeted at
the overwintering site yeah that's an
excellent question and we know that they
at least some portion of the population
certainly ends up in structures and
homes and things like that but in nature
it's a it's a big question what are the
preferred overwintering sites we've done
scouting and found them under sort of
bark on trees as well as sort of in
rocky crevices and things like that and
that's where they've been reported in
Asia as overwintering but again we we
don't know and so we have some
experiments designed this year to sort
of set up both understanding where they
overwinter most effectively and in terms
of survivorship but also try to trying
to track their movements to potential
overwintering sites carla is wondering
if there's any influence of temperature
or whether on insect movement yes both
at the high and low end we don't know
exactly what those thresholds are but at
lower temperatures we see them more than
likely just walking around you know so
it's definitely I don't know what that
threshold is and even at higher
temperatures on some of our hotter days
these bugs would hunker down and sort of
just rest but again we have to define
what those are okay and and the last one
for now Bob is wondering if they have
parasitoids for these insects in Asia
yes they do there is a species of wasp
in the in the family Cellini on add a
genus try sulcus that has been reported
to Paris
ties up to eighty percent of the eggs
and in fact those have been collected
and are in quarantine at our sister
facility in Newark Delaware dr. Kim
Homer has been screening these
potentially for release within the US
but again we're still very early in that
in that process and Fisher commented Bob
would probably like to go on a
collecting trip okay that'd be time to
ask more questions of Tracy at the end
Steve okay thank you well first I want
to thank Kathy and the organizers of the
webinar for inviting me to participate I
appreciate the chance to share some
things that are happening out here West
in California but first of all I want to
say I really enjoyed Tracy's
presentation learned a lot and makes me
glad I'm a plant pathologist because
some of those pictures are creeping me
out i don't think i would like to see
all those bugs around my house or my
events either so a very interesting
Tracy and I think my talk is a very
consistent and very appropriate to put
with Tracy because I'll be talking about
some recent challenges to strawberry out
west here which also involved new
problems and perhaps recent
introductions so some of the principles
and things might you know really mesh
well with what a Tracy talked about
I i think the is here is probably very
experienced but just to pull this all
together i'm going to be talking about
some soil-borne issues some new SAR born
issues on strawberry and so here's a
picture just showing us to remind us
that sorbonne problems by definition are
plant pathogens that are in the soil so
at the top left you can see what's
called lettuce dieback disease on
lettuce it's actually a very strange
pathogen this is a soil borne virus the
viruses in the soil it's spread in the
soil on the water and it is very
aggressive and causes significant
problems on certain types of lettuce
like this romaine picture here and the
bottom left here is a soil borne problem
on onion this is a white rot a very
destructive disease on that group of
plants and then to the right
verticillium wilt on strawberry probably
very familiar disease too many of you
and again a sore one problem so we're
just going to be talking about these new
issues that are so bored issues in
California and on strawberry and just to
pull together the basics of this type of
issue again I think a lot of you in the
audience already know this but there's
some very distinctive features of these
challenges that are in the soil first of
all they often survive for a very long
time these pathogens in the soil
sometimes can actually survive for
decades without a host plant there and
as you might guess that is a tremendous
headache for a producer for a grower
farmer because even if you're not
growing the crop the fungus or the
pathogen is still there so the very
long-term survivors in the soil and
they're often difficult to detect that's
not always the case we have some good
tools or some of these but in terms of
trying to know whether your field has
one or more of these problems it's not
always that easy to find out before you
plant the crop and before you see the
problem occur so sometimes difficult to
detect and find them and I probably add
to the slide there also difficult to
diagnose out touch on that later in the
presentation but sometimes knowing which
one you have is often not easy as I
mentioned these would be very damaging
we were talking about plant death or on
the on the brighter side just crop loss
of yields
these problems again very significant
economic factors in agriculture and part
of the reason why they're so important
and damaging is that they're easily
spread not quite like stink bugs but we
spread these ourselves meaning we as
farmers and growers and people for the
most part these are primarily spread as
contaminants in dirt or mud and unequip
matan tractors on trucks so probably the
growers and the pest controllers and
field walkers and are all these people
who are moving equipment and vehicles
around that's how we spread a lot of
these we can also spread them in
propagation material so that's another
factor but most of the time we're
spreading them in the dirt in which
they're found one problem in terms of
managing solvents or burn problems or
pathogens for the most part fungicides
are not very effective we could probably
find exceptions if we look around but
for the most part your fuse areum's your
verticillium Zahl these many soil-borne
problems don't respond well and are not
really controlled well by fungicides and
then often these pathogens have a wide
host range so you may be growing
strawberry or crop X you'll say well I
have too much of a problem the sobering
problem on strawberry I'll plant
something else often that other crop can
also be a host and will prolong that
problem so it's a complicated set of
factors here but this one slide kind of
summarizes these features of sovereign
pathogens so the issue that's happening
out in Californians are fairly recent
one and I'd like to walk you through
what's happening out here West regarding
this but i would say that even if you're
not out west here and you are strawberry
growers somewhere else in the country or
we grow some other crop and you don't
have these issues i still would argue
this might be of interest to you because
it kind of possibly mirrors or acts as a
model for what happens when new
pathogens are introduced to an area and
when new problems occur and how you
approach it how you diagnose these
things so i think again even if you're
not sharing our issue particularly at
the moment with Californians
the information and the history that
I'll show here certainly can reproduce
in your area with the different crop or
a different pathogen and by recent what
I mean is the dieback and collapse
issues on strawberry that are new we
first began to see in 2005 and
unfortunately from 2005 through the
presence we've seen an increasing
incidence meaning we've seen these
problems spread throughout the state of
California if in one county we had two
fields that had the problem in 2005 by
2010 there were 12 fields so we're
seeing more and more growers and more
and more ranches affected by that very
important to point out these new died
back and collapse problems which oh sure
you are not associated with and have
never been associated with the other
well known pathogens that already
occurrence strawberry so if you're a
strawberry person you know that there's
phytophthora issues and there's
verticillium and there's rhizoctonia you
know there are some well documented
historical soil borne pathogens on
strawberries these new problems i'm
showing you today have never been
associated with these other problems and
the other important association here
almost without exception these are
occurring in fields that no longer
receive the traditional fumigation
treatments so in california of course
you know our industry has really relied
on methyl bromide and chloropicrin flat
fumigation meaning were applying that
fumigation to the entire field not just
to the beds and that practice has really
made a successful in terms of yields and
dollar value these new problems are
occurring in these fields that no longer
receive that traditional flat fumigation
either because of cost or of course the
change in the regulations and with
methyl bromide leaving on its way out so
those factors not associated with
previous pathogens that are known took
her and occurring where we no longer
fumigate in the same traditional way
these are really hallmarks of these new
problems now today we know that there
are two major pathogens associated with
these problems
femina fade zolina which causes a
disease called charcoal rot and a strain
of fusarium oxysporum which causes
fusarium wilt on strawberry neither of
these were known to occur on starving
California prior to 2005
in terms of the history game what's
happening initially I'll show you some
maps but initially we only saw these
problems in Southern California where we
have our southern crop and now it's
occurring in other parts of California
and I'll illustrate that for you and
then in a second here i'm going to show
you what it looks like if you're not
familiar with these diseases but the
symptoms are very much characterized
here by this list you see the wilting of
plants there's overall poor growth and
performance and then as the disease
progresses and as you go into the season
eventually the plants will actually
collapse and die and then when you
examine these plants is very important
to dig them up out of the ground and cut
them up and look inside the plant you'll
see a very distinctive discoloration of
the inert issues primarily the crown so
let's take a look at these problems this
is the first one this is charcoal rot
caused by the fungus macro femina this
is a soil borne fungus that's known to
occur in soil and I believe you would
share my opinion that this is a
significant problem if you see this type
of photograph or if this is your field
we have distinct areas where a large
percentage of the plants collapse and
die as pictured here just a little
closer up look to show you again macro
femina or charcoal rot occurring on
strawberry and plants especially the one
in the bottom Center photo showing
advanced cases where they're collapsing
the photo in the upper right and let me
try and get these trained me on this
arrow here hopefully you could see that
the photo on the upper right this is a
collapse plant and i pointed out to you
now because later i'll talk about
diagnosing and trying to identify these
problems and here i would argue and
debate with you the fact that this type
of symptom looks very much like it could
be in fact with verticillium so again if
you're looking to say identify this just
based on the picture or on a visual of
the plant i think that's a dangerous
assumption because this is macro femina
and not verticillium
inch to two diagnosis or to assist in
diagnosing it you need to dig up these
plants and cut them open and the macro
for me always show is a very distinctive
discoloration in the crown here you know
already that the healthy plant tissue
will be cream-colored or light-colored
like this but the infected plant with
macro firmino will have these very
distinctly dark discolored sections of
the crown and here are three examples of
that
you
now what we do here in California course
in all states where you have plant
pathologists like myself you give these
plants to a plant pathologist and
they'll take out through a sterile
procedure they'll take out small bits of
that crown tissue and put it in a petri
plate with appropriate media and that's
what you see in the upper left here and
that's black speculate colony growing
out from those strawberry pieces that is
the macro femina and this is the way you
confirm the presence of this pathogen in
strawberry crowns and then I mentioned
earlier one reason why these pathogens
like macro femina are so dangerous and
bothersome they last in the soil for a
long time and here in the large photo in
the front you could see why every one of
these little black specks is one
survival structure this is called a
microscale ocean and every single one of
these little black specks is a like a
seat for the fungus it is a very hard
it's black which means its resist
ultraviolet light and it's able to
survive and persistence oil for a
prolonged period of time and this is
what the fungus makes to enable it to
survive to the next crop to the next
strawberry crop this particular
photograph shows the size to there's my
trusty penny at the bottom and this has
grown in a sand and cornmeal medium so
here you can see these little crystals
and pieces here these are little grains
of sand so this use your idea of the
size of the micro scrotum how they're
very small and how if the fungus is
making these these are easily
transported in contaminated soil these
can be in the soil in just a clot of mud
on a tractor or disc and when you move
that disc to a clean field you've moved
these micros closure so this shows again
why that's a problem for our growers and
people in Ag okay so that's the first
problem the second one is fusarium wilt
and it's basically following the same
pattern here recently introduced in
California not seen before in California
soil-borne problem spread in the soil
and we began by seeing in small patches
the photograph at the top
was what we began to see and I think
2006 actually where these small areas
and our strawberry fields began to
collapse and die and over time these
patches got larger the photograph in the
bottom on the front shows a couple years
later where these patch these patches
gotten much larger more plants are
affected and we're beginning to be very
concerned about spread to new areas
here's a close-up event that this is
fusarium wilt on strawberry against our
second new development in fields that
are no longer receiving the traditional
flat fume treatment and in a second i'll
talk about diagnosing these but again I
would argue that you and I we cannot
separate this photograph from the macro
fahmida once the plant symptoms are
identical and also resemble verticillium
wilt
again you need to dig up these plants
and look at them and cut them open and
again just like the mecca femina the
fusarium wilt causes a very distinctive
dark discoloration in the inner crown
tissue and so again one cannot diagnosis
turkey by looking at the outer collapse
you have to dig up the plant cut up in
the crowd and look for this type of
symptom inside now as I've just shown
you with macro femina I'm telling you
this is fusarium so how you say well how
can you separate these where you cannot
separate again based on the symptoms so
you take these plans to your friendly
neighborhood neighborhood plant
pathologist and we will again plate
pieces of that strawberry tissue on the
appropriate medium and look for what
grows out and in this case this is the
fusarium which has a different look to
it it's has a very pinkish color in this
medium and we can diagnose it based on
this recovery the photograph and the
lower left shows you the survival
structures for this fungus these are
called chlamydia spores it functions
very much the same as those black specks
of the macro femina it survives in the
soil for a prolonged period of time it
resists weathering and this is how the
fungus survives between crops and from
year to year
to show you our dilemma or our issue and
concern here are two snapshots in time
as you will for our state regarding
macro femina in 2005 we began to see
detect and confirm the macro femina on
strawberry california and it was only in
two counties we have a significant
strawberry industry in Ventura County in
Orange County so those are the two
orange I'm sorry those with two pink
stars they're so 2005 we began to get
concern for our Southern California
growers because of this problem
unfortunately where we fast forward now
to 2010 2010 we have a number of other
counties that also report and have
confirmed the same a cure for me to
unstrap airy as you probably know our
major area of strawberry production
California is is the central part of the
state all the way down through the south
so this is Monterey County lacks where
I'm located here in Salinas this is
Monterey County from Monterey County
south we have the majority of the
state's strawberries and you can see
that four of the major five counties for
strawberry in this area have the macro
femina the four counties to the north
have smaller more limited strawberry
industries so the acreage is limited but
they also have the problem so you could
see why we're concerned about the future
when you have the spread and increasing
incidents throughout our state so that's
microphone Mina and here I want to show
you a similar pattern although at this
point fewer stars thankfully for
fusarium wilt on strawberry 2006 was the
first year we confirmed fusarium on
strawberry in California and you can see
that the only place we found it was in
ventura and then we fast forward to 2010
we have two sites two counties with the
fusarium that's good news bad news the
good news is it has not spread to say
ten or eight counties the bad news is
however the fuse erm has been found in
one of our major strawberry producing
areas and that's my home
ace in Monterey County here in the
Central Coast of California so even
though they're only two counties
affected these two counties probably
account for i would estimate sixty-five
to seventy percent of our state's
strawberry production so even though
it's not statewide yet the fusarium has
touched down in our two major producing
counties in terms of the distribution as
of last year just for background
information macrosomia is not a new
disease in california only it's also
occurring in other parts of the world
and i might add is very interesting to
note that for all these other parts of
the world reporting macro femina it's
primarily showing up again in locations
where they no longer use methyl bromide
so Egypt France India Israel and Spain
these places are reporting macro femina
on strawberry and these are places where
they are not using the traditional
fumigation practice anymore for macro
familia we need to add australia
australia is another country that has
macro femina on its strawberry in the
USA maybe some of you know about this I
don't know where you all are from but
right now in strawberry it's been
confirmed and reported in California
Florida and Illinois and then I talked
to you earlier about the counties in my
own state with that map for the
distribution of fusarium if you zoom
slightly different than that refer me
that microphone is a new worldwide
development and what I mean by new is
you know in the year two thousand and
Counting that's when macro femina began
to be reported on strawberry fusarium is
a little bit different fusarium is not a
brand new disease because the believes
the japanese and maybe the koreans
reported fusarium back in the 1960s in
1919 70s and i think australia also has
had it a long time so if user mode on
strawberry has been in the world a
longer time and then fortunate now we in
the USA or just added to that list of
infested countries the 4s is brand new
in california for whatever reason the
few
wilt disease on strawberry has been
reported in California and South
Carolina in terms of USA States so let's
talk a minute here about something that
I think is extremely practical for
almost all of you probably a
participating and listening in today and
that is diagnosing you know if you're a
grower or a pest control advisor or you
walk fields and make recommendations or
your sales person selling products to
farmers and people in Ag you know that
it's extremely important and critical
actually to identify and know what the
problems are I mean if you see a stink
bug on your crop you better call Tracy
to find out which one it is right you
need to know what what the problem is
and have a precise identification of the
problem and for pathogens that
originated in the soil that's very much
a challenge and as this photograph here
illustrates I'd be glad to bet with you
your lunch money about which pathogen or
pathogens might be responsible for these
symptoms the point is you can't tell and
I as a professional who work with these
12 months of the year I cannot tell
which pathogens are responsible for
these die back problems because it could
be one of our new issues at macro femina
or fusarium or it could be one of the
old time favorites verticillium
phytother we do not know and I want to
use just a couple minutes here to
illustrate why this is a very big
challenge and why it's important to
recognize the issue so the first
challenge is with our new issues here
are new problems the macro for me and
fusarium in my mind are virtually
identical in terms of the symptoms poor
growth stunting dieback plant collapse
discoloration of that crown which I
showed you and also haven't talked about
this too much but very much stress
related both of these pathogens can
really cause the most severe damage when
the crop is stressed and that is either
through environmental extremes when it's
very hot and dry or there's little bit
of water stress if you're
you're half a day or a day late watering
and the plants a little bit under stress
because of that water shortage the these
pathogens very aggressive and cause much
more damage and much more rapid
development of problems under stress so
for Mac refer me to fusarium both of
these act the same they look the same
you and I cannot separate them readily
without a laboratory tests so diagnosing
these are going to be a problem for you
their problem for me and then to expand
this a little bit I mentioned the old
time favorites marcelin phytophthora for
the most part these symptoms and
features are shared by all four of these
problems the two new ones macro femina
and fusarium and the old ones / distal
in fact offer so if you have these types
of symptoms in general it's going to be
very difficult for you to know what's
going on without the support and help of
a laboratory or an extension pathologist
or someone who can actually have things
tested the one exception here is fight
authors really not considered a stress
organism you can have if I talk through
issues on strawberries that are growing
quite well in fact as you know being a
water mode it likes lots of moisture in
the soil so the stress thing is it's not
quite relevant here there's some good
questions here if it's I think it would
be a good chance to take these right now
are these problems worse under plastic
culture maybe Teresa can send me a
follow-up question I'm wondering if you
need plastic culture meeting large hoop
houses that cover the whole planted area
or plastic covered beds that the plastic
is just covering the beds and the plants
are planted into that so I need that
have these diseases ever been observed
in fumigated fields we have seen them in
fumigated fields again we need to
qualify this here in California our
experience is primarily with the
production fields these production
fields have been fumigated with
alternatives not the methyl bromide
chloropicrin they have been fumigated
with these new replacement materials we
are seeing the
diseases in those situations if it's
fumigated with methyl bromide chlorin at
the appropriate rate and that's the
traditional treatment we do not see and
have not seen those problems so yes we
are seeing them if Yuma gated fields and
these are ones that again are in the new
world being treated with alternative
materials okay and then finally the
question about nursery stock as of right
now and I think we need more information
from the nursery producers in our state
we have not heard of significant
problems of these two new pathogens in
the nursery production counties have not
seen that and we do receive materials
from them for testing for other things
and so far I've never isolated macro
femina or fusarium from transplants
coming from those areas we do get the
old standards so the vertices and fight
off for colic toxic them but no we have
not seen these new ones from transplants
yet okay Teresa got back to me see the
question is okay so I think she's asking
do we see these problems or are they
worse in fields where the beds are
covered with plastic and then the plants
are planted into the plastic as opposed
to the use of straw or mulch as a
covering of the bed for us in California
you may know this we do not use anything
except plastic we don't use straw or
mulch covers for strawberry production
so we only see it in in the beds with
the plastic but that's because all
strawberries are planted into plastic
covered beds so as of right now I don't
know the how that might now that dynamic
might play out for other types of bed
covering and then the last question that
I move on for a second here the question
is matt has macro fahmida let's see
question is can mac refer me to be a
problem in temperate in a temperate
climate zone and i'm only a mere Plant
Pathology so I need to define for me
exactly what temperate climate means
this temperate mean
me here in central California
Mediterranean type climates i'll look
for the rebuttal reply of that i'll go
ahead here and get to that question in a
second ok so we in California have these
problems hopefully you won't but the way
things move in the world and with these
new developments perhaps you will so
what are we collectively going to do
about dealing with these problems again
I think an audience like this today
you're probably very experienced so you
could do this slide you could put this
together you would approach the macro
femina or fusarium issues the same as
you would any other sober an issue
that's nothing novel about that what is
novel is the fact we have new pathogens
on strawberry in California and what's
novel is we're in an era where we're
losing the main tool methyl bromide that
has been used in years past two to
defeat these these challenges so that's
what's novel whereas not in all of us
how you deal with it it's going to be
the same as with other soul burn issues
so first of all select the appropriate
site I mean if you have the flexibility
and the ability to just move off site
don't plant in an area that reports a
history of this problem if you know that
this field over here down the road has
macro formula then you would not be well
advised to lease that ground then plant
strawberry next year stay away from
known infested sites very important is
crop rotation if you're a diversified
grower and you grow things more than
strawberry just don't plan something
that's a host don't plant strawberry
don't have time to go into this today
but we know or feel that this fungus
will affect other crops that are known
to be hosts of macro femina so examples
pepper so if you have a disease
strawberry field don't plant pepper
there either and don't plan it
strawberry anymore try rotate crops you
know plant lettuce plant broccoli plant
petunias plant things that are not a
host rotate away from that problem
rotate away from strawberry for
conventional growers fumigate
he remains a tool a management tool but
the question is which materials i'll
show you a slide near the end here that
shows our work in california that
indicates some of the alternatives do
control the macro formula and fusarium
but it's not one hundred percent and we
are getting escapes and we're getting a
reinvest ation of these problems so
that's not the answer in itself we do
have fumigation that will help but it
will not eradicate the problem because
it's not as good as methyl bromide
chloropicrin if you have access to
resistance strawberry cultivars that is
obviously a good management tool for
solar burn problems I'll again show you
at the end some of our work we show that
there are differences in the varieties
and so we have the ability to maybe in
the future breed for some resistant
varieties as a right now we don't have
true resistance but we have varieties
that are more tolerant plant those if
those are available if they fit your
your situation as I mentioned to you
both the new problems are definitely
stress-related plants that are stressed
from environmental extremes and I think
I forgot to mention fruit load plants
are distressed with a very very heavy
fruit load that's good for you the
grower that's bad for a strawberry plant
that's already infected with macro
femina a heavy fruit load puts a
physiological stress on plants and that
will definitely create the onset of very
severe and fast developing symptoms for
these problems and finally of course we
talked about soil if you are moving
dirty soil infested soil from place to
place between fields you are going to
move these pathogens so stop that don't
do that we're having more more growers
actually wash off equipment it's a big
pain in the neck but it's something that
is extremely important if you want a
safeguard clean fields in the long run
okay let me quickly take a couple more
questions here okay oh great question
there's a question about whether you can
have this problem show up in cooler
climates like Northern Europe Poland
Germany very good question and
I would say of course you we never want
to say never so we can't say that but we
can say that macro femina entries area
are both well known as warmer
temperature pathogens so both of these
pathogens prefer warmer soils and I
think I won't go back here but you can
see from the slides in general a lot of
those countries that report the problem
tend to have areas where the climate is
very warm so as of right now we haven't
had any of these reports from say Norway
so I would think that the Akula climates
would either not have an issue with
these on strawberry or if you eventually
have the issue the severity of the
problem may be lessened because of the
cooler climate of both these pathogens
like warmer temperatures and I know
that's relevant a relative but still I
think Northern European production might
not have the same issue okay and I can
remember of Tracy if we I think we got
Tracy's question she's going to be
leaving us soon a question from Bob Oh
does this prom occur in soybean Illinois
or in soybean anywhere i guess we're
plants are under stress and yes the
answer is yes macro femina is a
well-known pathogen of soybean so
soybean has been a known host of mecca
for me deferred for a decade or longer
prior long time and so that's very much
a known part of the problems for soybean
and I don't know about the stress thing
for soybean but I imagine the profiles
similar if the soybeans are under water
stress or other issues we do tendency
macro for you to develop faster on any
crop under stress so definitely yes to
that good question so in the time I have
left with you just a little bit about
our research to highlight what we
discussed earlier so there are
differences in strawberry varieties in
terms of susceptibility to the mecca for
Mena and we're doing similar work with
this on fusarium as well just want to
show you a little bit of information
here so for example in this scale a
bigger number is bad so diamante here at
the bottom the maximum is 5
diamante has the 4.9 disease severity
ranking that means that it's a extremely
decimated by the macro femina when you
infect it however the seascape has a 2.9
it is significantly more tolerant to the
fuse area I start to the mecca for Mena
it holds up much better but I hasten to
add that it has a 2.9 we would like to
see a 1 point 0 there a 1 point 0 means
basically no symptoms the plant is not
affected by the macro femina and we are
looking at a resistant plant seascape is
not resistant but it is more tolerant so
it holds up better but it is still
diseased but this shows you that our
hope is to develop varieties that are
resistant and so that we would have a
chance to develop that and replace the
ones that are very sensitive bob is
asking are these numbers the severity
index numbers here related to crop load
in this particular experiment no in fact
I'll show you the next photograph this
is a controlled experiment in a shade
house we inoculated potted strawberry
plants just to see the basic reaction to
the fungus and this does not have
anything to do with harvest fruit load
or just the fruit load of the plant
itself so no it is strictly
susceptibility of the plant to the
fungus and this is what I'm talking
about Bob so here is our seascape on the
far right it has been injected with the
macro for me that just like the other
varieties but you can see that even
though their inoculate at the same time
the albiana ventana are much more
sensitive to the macro femina the
seascape holds it much better however if
I gave you the seascape plant and you
cut it open you can see slight
discoloration in the crown meaning that
it has been infected and if you wait
long enough the seascape will start to
show collapse problems as well but it
will take a much longer time to develop
then
it's kind of summarizing the work
overall in terms of some of the
resistant varieties so let's look at the
column here from macro femina I just
showed you seascape seascape and
Chandler are two strawberry varieties
that are we're calling it resistant
resistant does not mean immune immune
means you don't even get infection but
they are infected but Chandler and
seascape hold up much better to macro
fahmida than say the varieties monterey
san andreas in ventana which are
extremely susceptible or sensitive and
the other column of the fusarium however
the channel and seascape unfortunately
are very susceptible so if you have both
of these problems in your field one or
the other is going to get you
unfortunately if you inject these plants
of fusarium the monterey san andreas and
ventana are resistant so that's good
news but of course as I mentioned they
are susceptible to the macro femina so
we have the unfortunate situation where
there's not yet one variety that will
withstand both of the new challenges in
California
okay then
talk about chemicals so the deal is as I
mentioned we're losing the methyl
bromide chloropicrin the the standard
methyl bromide corporate grin at a high
rate used as a flat fume application in
California to treat the whole field that
is going out and we strongly believe
that is why these new problems are
coming in the old traditional means of
control x going out so the new pathogens
are coming in so we have looked at
alternative treatments the list is here
to see if there's something else that
can really help us in combating these
problems and two things to note here one
there's a lot of different treatments I
won't take the time to go through this
but a lot of different treatments this
is one of several one of three
experiments were doing in this type of
research to find an answer to these
solar problems so we have a lot of
alternatives we're looking at secondly
the photograph is important to remind me
to tell you these are applied to the bed
in California we're getting away from
applying it to the whole field the
public opinion the regulator's the
general direction of the world is a way
from using all these chemicals at high
rates and high volumes so one way to
address that is just to apply it to the
beds the beds are preformed they're
almost ready to plant the the fumigation
material the fumigant material is then
injected or applied to the beds
sometimes applied through the drips drip
irrigation that's in the bed already and
then later after time has elapsed the
plants are put into the beds that's best
fumigation so we're applying these
materials in this system in this bed she
negation method and again time will
allow me to do this or go through this
individually nor do you want me to do
that the bottom line is if we saw
something that was equivalent to a
methyl bromide chloropicrin traditional
fumigation the bar would reach the
number one here but go no further we are
looking at trying to get something
equivalent to a level one in terms of
disease severity you can see the good
news here the good news is a lot of
these alternatives the first nine or so
control the
problem quite well and so they're doing
a good job at controlling or at least
knocking down populations the bad news
is they are not comparable to that level
one they all allow some macro fahmida
and some fusarium to creep through and
that's what we're continuing to see in
these fields we do see die back and
collapse even though the field the plots
have been applied with these materials
and you can see a controls number ten so
over here we on the right that's
something that is not acceptable and we
have three treatments that are about the
same as a control so our situation
California we say none of the new
alternatives some of which can already
be used will give you the same level of
control and we are seeing breakthrough
in some disease occurring despite the
use of those new alternative materials
so I think I'm about done here in
summary have walked you through to new
soil borne issues in California for our
strawberry producers these are fairly
recent developments we're not unique we
in California share these problems with
other places in the world and the
country but being the country's number
one strawberry producing state we're
quite concerned about these new problems
caused by macro femina and fusarium hope
I made my case to you a precise field
diagnosis is not possible so if you are
in a different state and you began to
see begin to see die back issues in your
strawberries I encourage you to again
locate your friendly neighborhood plant
pathologists or someone qualified to
help you with diagnosis because it will
take the laboratory testing to confirm
what you've got there and again the way
things happen in our country and our
world with movement of materials and
such you likely will see some new
disease at some point maybe not these
two but something in the future if they
are something you'll see you'll be
likely to be considered like we are that
these are going to be persistent
problems that will need to be deal with
a long-term strategy and again really
excuse me there's really nothing new in
terms of the strategies they'll be
similar to what we do for other soul
burn problems and I went through that
with you that's basically nothing new
there but something that will have to be
applied now too
new issues at least your strawberry okay
bye Tracy before me I also want to thank
a lot of people especially the
strawberry growers in my state of
California and we have a very nice
industry group the California Strawberry
Commission that's funded our research
and then there's lots of people who have
helped us with the project as well as
our research team really why acknowledge
all those people and again I really want
to thank Kathy and organizers for
allowing me to share this with you today
and with that I will pass us back to
Kathy okay thank you very much Steve and
Tracy are there questions for either of
our speakers while you're thinking about
that thank you for participating today i
want to remind you that the second in
the series on emerging pass ID and
management will be next friday afternoon
at the same time they'll have dr. robert
martin was going to be talking to us
about strawberry viruses and then mr.
mark boulder was going to be talking to
us about management of spotted wing
Drosophila in small fruits
so while we're waiting for questions I
also want to point out to you oh the box
is not here anyway I have posted the
first two recordings online and they are
available and I will be editing last
week in this week's webinars hopefully
this afternoon and have those posted
sometime early next week
yeah oh here comes somebody okay
okay no questions yet here is the link
for the webinar recordings
you
okay if there are no questions thanks
again speakers we really appreciate your
participation and we'll see all of you
next week yep thank you everybody thanks
Kathy
you
you